of the boot camp and I am delighted to
introduce valtanan who is going to tell
us about algebraic abstraction as you
know in order to build the database or
say a query Optimizer you're going to
need a few abstractions algorithmic ones
Arabic ones and
um
you know including in order to kind of
debug you know if you write a query and
you would like to know what's going on
in the middle of execution you will need
some kind of provenance information in
order to know you know trace the
execution path so this abstraction is
going to help us with that too so um
as well thank you very much uh quite
right on this indeed
uh one hopes there are even more
applications perhaps than we thought
about I will introduce a different
motivation
um that also uh
goes to you'd like to know what's going
on I think that is something that we all
want to
have a good idea when we query databases
uh so this is uh part of a series of
four lectures and as in the first and
second day
um we are grouped together in four
lectures but
um ours are actually both morning where
both morning people I suppose then and
I'll give the first two this morning and
then we'll give the next to
uh tomorrow morning and this is what uh
uh we're gonna talk about
um so
uh it's difficult because I I will have
to be immodest for a for a while maybe
some of you think that that's it
um algebraic methods have been applied
successfully in database Theory and what
I'm going to begin with is to survey one
application that I think justifies
um
that the the claim that algebraic
methods can be very helpful
um when we started this work in 2007
this was a little less clear but
there were also some supporting
there was uh some sporting research
around those years but since then I was
absolutely delighted to see that
that
this
abstract understanding has actually
helped us in a variety of ways and
you'll see in fact some
a perspective that I loved that Dan will
present tomorrow
so uh
the overwhelming motivation originally
for
what I'm gonna tell you about was Data
sharing
so this is an old story in databases
when when I started working seriously in
databases when my colleague Peter
binerman converted me from programming
language
Theory this was the big deal it was
called actually data integration but in
fact you know these are related topics
um and here we are 30
years later more than 30 years later and
it's still not clear that data
integration is a completely
satisfactorily solved issue so data
sharing appears in several guises when
people build warehouses collecting data
from various sources
and a good example that we were very
much
motivated by is collaborating scientists
so uh the
first project that was done with this
was called Orchestra it was the
brainchild of my colleague Zach Ives
and uh the semi-ring
framework for database provenance was
developed in order to support
this idea of data sharing in order to
for let's say a bunch of scientists who
exchange information
to understand how to deal with each
other
I will explain with a I hope not too
simplistic
example
so uh let's say that you know I can I
can only take in vain the name of a few
people but I feel comfortable with them
and so deeper and so so let's say that
Dan and the Val are zoologists who just
collect information
and then has determined without any
doubt that cats eat mice and rats
and Val has determined that uh his uh
is the color specialist he's determined
that mice are gray and the red okay
and rats are gray
now sudipa on the other hand uh and
there are many more scientists nowadays
are data scientists and they are I'd
like to call them computational
scientists that is they're not going in
the field there to to chase mice to see
what color they have they just collect
data from a whole bunch of other people
who do create these data sources
and then they create information by
integrating it so that's an aspect of
data sharing and so Deepa
looking at dance notes and Val's notes
determines that
for some reason okay this the conception
is is quite uh bizarre for some reason
so Deepa is interested in the color of
the food of animals So based on this
information so Deepa determines
computationally that cats eat both gray
and red food okay
now at the same time when scientists
collaborate they have different opinions
about each other's reliability
that's a very serious problem not just
in this funny example but in reality
and so uh you know for various reasons
she has her doubts about some of Val's
work in particular that mice are read
and but she has you know great trust in
dance work
so she would like to annotate her data
with trust
and the first approach to this would be
quite simplistic we're just going to
label the tuples as trust or don't trust
so the Y's which are supposed to be
green how green are they then
the wise mean yes okay so
um what sudipa does you know presumably
Dan doesn't have an opinion about how
good his data is but what zodipa does is
whatever she Imports which Imports those
tuples from then she uh labels them that
yes Trust
uh she has obtained Through the
Grapevine the information that valves
data about mice is highly suspicious
so she labels with n from no the the two
tuples about the color of mice
but she also heard that Val's
information about rats is more reliable
so sure okay so the question is given
these annotations on the two data
sources then and vowels how should
sudeepa compute or her algorithms how
should they compute
annotations on her data
what of her what part of her data is to
be trusted and what not
so now obviously the cat eating red
stuff that's you know not to be trusted
but here is an interesting situation it
is still
to be trusted that cats eat gray food
and why is that that's because
of the rats which are gray not because
of the mice which are gray
so this you see uh already introduced
this idea that there are alternative
ways of deriving
data that we need to somehow capture
okay
it turns out that I'm gonna yes
yeah this is a calculation of yes
as a Boolean combination of yes and no
uh think of them as false and true
no it isn't so no is why and no so if if
no is false then you know there's
conjunction here
these are the annotations of sudeep as
to goals computed from the annotations
of vowels and dance to both using a kind
of Boolean combination okay okay so so
for the moment I'm just proposing this
as an intuitive thing and maybe if
that's all that so deeper does with some
data it doesn't maybe need a lot of uh
sophisticated framework except these
kind of calculations okay all right
but it turns out that
um you can also think of other
applications and one would be for
example access control and here it is
perhaps done in val who actually have
labels of some of their data and sudipa
agrees that the you know there are
certain controls on how much the data
will be shared so for that who is you
know a reliable
General scientist makes his data P
public
well who you know already His science is
a little suspicious
labels the mouse information P from Top
Secret so it's gonna share it only with
people that like him
and but when it comes to to the right
information he labels it see for
confidential more generally you can have
a hierarchy like this of of Access
Control scores
that you can label public confidential
secret top secret
and the problem is how does uh so deep
if she agrees you know to follow the
desires of the sources where she gets
the data how should she label her output
tuples
and notice that she would like to label
the information about cat eating red
food to label it as top secret and
that's because Val's information here
about mice being ready stop secret and
that's the only way only with this top
secret information can you get the fact
that cats eat red stuff on the other
hand when you get to Saint Catherine
gray stuff you can also get it through
the rack information and that's only
confidential so it doesn't have to be
labeled top secret okay
well I'm also trying to amuse you come
on
[Laughter]
now this is a very sort of
uh categorical but in fact
in reality people do not have binary
opinions about trust they have
confidence course
and you'd like to work with those as
well so for example let's say that dance
tuples we have of confidence of 0.9 so
confidence scores here are between zero
and one point nine
um and we have a 0.6 confidence in the
mouse being gray and point one only
confidence in the mouse being red and
0.8 for the rat and then you'd like to
again propagate this confidence scores
into the output somehow and here is one
possible calculation that you can do I'm
not saying it's the only one but it does
fit our semi-ring frame framework and
that's why I'm selling it
when you actually use two tuples so for
example the fact that cat eats mouse and
mouse is red you multiply 0.9 with 0.1
that is you multiply the con confidence
course which makes sense in a sort of
not quite probabilistic sense but
similar if they are independent in some
sense but at the same time
um you also know that uh Rat is gray and
Cat it's red and that's a much better
confidence score 0.9 times 0.8 that's
0.72 and then how do you compare the two
which one should you choose the proposal
is to choose the maximum yes
uh
um the algebra work for
um
no
not quite
so there is a problem with with negation
which I'm not okay so that's earlier
so I I had to make some choices I can
give a whole one-hour talk about how to
deal with negation I will have some
things to say at the very end but for
the moment uh all the queries that we
are considering do not use negative
information and they they are let's say
a positive relational algebra
yeah
um and they also this also works for
data log but you're going to hear from
them tomorrow
okay
so
um the story of how data depends how
outputs depend on inputs
um
has gotten from Peter bunerman the
lovely name provenance actually his joke
is
that lineage it's for Kings
and you're not going to believe this but
some some scientists actually refer to
what we call lineage and provenance in
database refer to it as pedigree
now pedigree Peter says it's of course
for dogs and horses
and provenance is the elegant word for
it because you know it's for works of
art
so anyway I'm I'm in the provenance Camp
although I do know that there are some
people who make it a point
to use the word lineage
so
so provenance that is this kind of
relationship is time captured how so
deepest data depends on the input data
from that animal but how
we try to capture provenances an
abstract way of describing these
dependence
and the previous examples these three
examples that I gave you I can use them
as sanitygx or as sort of things to
generalize from
um and what I would like to do and
that's really very important is I would
like to use provenance only once and
then the previous examples I'd like to
specialize them from provenance so that
I don't have to do the Providence
calculator the tracking through the
queries all the time I can just look at
the final result and evaluate provenance
for a particular application like trust
in those
uh with those confidence scores or
access control or we shall see some
other applications
so to do that we will abstractly label
the input to pose
for lack of a better name we call these
abstract labels provenance tokens
what you'd like to do is to propagate
this provenance through the query
and as you propagate it it's going to
take the form of Expressions because it
gets more complicated as it combines the
tokens and these expressions are going
to annotate tuples not just in the
intermediate results but then eventually
in the final result of the query
as you analyze as we did at that time as
you analyze what's happening to how data
is used throughout the database
operations
you can identify quite clearly two
different
manners in which the the data is used
one is jointly there is for example in
the join right like you had in the
previous example
seems to keep us query
but also alternatively so that's because
for instance
you can for example have a projection
and the same information is actually
coming from alternative tupulous in the
final answer
so
the proposal is to actually postulate
two algebraic operations
um and to see how you can use them to
combine provenance
things that you'd like to have is of
course if you you know like good things
in computer science right you'd like a
compositionality input output
compositionality so if you compose
queries things work out smoothly
you'd like modularity you'd like to be
able to define something for every
operator
okay
so how are we going to set this up
imagine that X is uh the set of
provenance tokens that we use to label
the input tuples
and then problem X is the set of this
annotation the space of annotations
these Expressions involving that
provenance tokens that propagate through
the query
and we're gonna talk about relations in
which the tuples are annotated as probe
of X relation so this is a relation in
which every Tuple is annotated with a
provenance expression in fact more
generally we are going to talk about
talk about K relations where the
annotations come from some more even
more General space k
but at this point the question is what
is k
and of course it's going to be the same
meetings right
so on probex or on K you want to have
these two binary operations the joint
and the alternative and just to
summarize you use joint use in
operations like join Cartesian product
intersection and use alternative use uh
in unions and projections questions
by the way anytime you saw you you gave
the example interrupt the speaker
anytime we do that here a lot
so in addition and that's a little less
obvious at the beginning you'd like some
special annotations
uh so this is an annotation called zero
which is
we're going to think of it as
as labeling apps and tuples you can say
what well uh the point is that
as
you operate on the on on the input data
and so on and for example you delete
some of the tuples you'd like to see
what happens in the output
and
setting things to zero is a very nice
and elegant way to to track this through
provenance and you'd like to see what is
going to be zero in the output if
something becomes zero in the input
the second uh slightly unusual
annotation is one
so The annotation one corresponds to
data that you choose not to track so
remember you have those provenance
tokens that you label a tuple with and
you want to know what happens to that
Tuple how is that Tuple used in
throughout your transformation query
transformation and so on and the
question is
if you choose not to track that well you
can label it with one
and that will
one will sort of go along and not bother
anybody else until the end of the
calculation
okay
so how does this work I did not
emphasize before but I had
this uh conjunctive query here that
really was calculating so deepa's data
so this is uh so deeper stable is s of x
and z and it is the
so this is a join followed by a
projection
it's a simplest example that I could
think so it doesn't take too much space
but as you have more complicated
relation algebraic expressions you these
kind of Expressions can become even more
complicated
so what you see here is
an abstract way of what I was trying to
tell you is those
suggesting how those calculations with
yes and no with the access control
always the confidence scores were
proceeding so if you think of these
tuples as labeled p and q r s and t then
um the Tuple that cats eat gray stuff
would be labeled with P times R plus Q
times T notice the plus there that
corresponds to those Alternatives that
we were talking about in the beginning
well the Tuple cat it's red stuff is
labeled by P dot s and for the moment
this is an abstract operation it's the
abstract version for example so p r plus
Q T is the abstract version of that 0.72
calculation that I showed you before
that takes the maximum between two
products
okay
so with this setup it turns out that you
can do the following nice things
you can Define uh for each select
project join Union operator uh in terms
of of K relations of relations which are
um
annotated with elements from this space
which for the moment is Ambiguously the
space of provenance expressions and some
space k but we're going to see exactly
what the general form is
and then if you do that then
compositionality follows from the usual
composition I'll let your algebraic
expression so that's why algebraze
algebra is giving you for free a whole
bunch of things
so
um that gives us a k relational algebra
that is a relation algebra on K
expressions
on K relations okay relations having
tuples annotated with elements from some
K so this K is a space of annotations it
is now an algebraic structure okay with
operations plus times zero and one and
the question is okay you have to buy
operations to constant but what actions
do they satisfy and the nice thing is
that
it turns out that uh if you want the K
relational algebra
definitions to satisfy the standard
query optimization equivalence but I
also say standard for back semantics
because there is one thing that we want
to include in this whole thing and that
is black semantics because if you do
have set semantics then you have for
example Union would be item potent but
that's not the case with back semantic
so we want to cover everything but in
fact these are the those optimizations
which are used uh typically in in an
Optimizer if if the optimizer works on
relational expressions
and this happens if you want those
things to hold exactly when this case is
a commutative summary I'll have the
definition of community saving in a
moment
it can Define can be defined not just on
you know select project join Union you
can also give a definition for
conjunctive queries unions of
conjunctive queries non-recursive data
log and as you will see tomorrow full
data log
and more I'll have at the end I will
have some sort of
mostly for the purposes of giving you a
bibliographical pointers uh how far this
this framework has been extended and
things that you are used to so for
example translating between unions of
conjunctive ways and spju back and forth
all these translations are sound in K
relation algebra as long as K is a
commutative same meaning
so what is a commutative summary so
not sure uh how much I can rely on but
let's hope that we are familiar you know
with uh with rings which are
things like the integers and polynomials
with for example the integer but
coefficients but also more generally
uh you know the real numbers the complex
numbers Etc
a semi ring is actually a ring without
additive inverses so you have a plus but
there is no inverse for Plus
so plus has to be associative Community
with identity zero that's as usual in
every ring
times has to be associative the identity
is one so that's actually some
definitions of ring do not include that
but we do
then
times has to distribute over plus that's
very important if you want things like
pushing
projections into joins or into
uh unions and stuff all that good stuff
that we're used to
um this better be distributive we just
you you never thought that you're using
that as you were checking those
identities but you were
and finally times is commutative I'll
spend 20 seconds on that the use of semi
rings in computer science is very old I
mean computer science is not very old to
begin with but okay
so it goes back
to the late 50s when people like Chomsky
and chuchenberger were actually working
on uh
formal languages and there is a very
natural way in which say meetings are
used to generalize properties of formal
languages
but in formal languages there is no
natural
commutativity of multiplication so most
of those applications so you're gonna
see you know you look at the entire
chapters in handbooks and and
encyclopedias and so on but those things
assume that multiplication is is not
commutative in general for us it is
commutative and that's because you know
join is commutative
um and that makes an interesting
difference although it is actually also
uh useful to know results that are more
General than that and see how they apply
and that's going to say a few things
about that maybe about
yeah things like so those of you who
know about cleaning algebras and the
wonderful wonderful work of Dexter cause
and maybe that clicks let me
so for the second who has to over
here
eight times zero to
um so you see Zero is supposed to
annotate absent tuples
so if you have a tuple and you join it
with a tuple that's not there
there's nothing to that comes out of it
so I find I find it inevitable right
can you do something without it I don't
know I mean
there's always somebody who uses who
generalizes things that's that's a it's
a it's it's not a theorem yes
rules is not used but it's there seems
to be sometimes implied is the fact that
you can't get zero by other means so you
don't have April A and B so that's a
plus b equals zero
yeah so what happens is that in order to
make that thing work we had to do for
example so in order to present the
semi-rings so what Pierre is saying is
that
um sometimes there is no natural zero
but you kind of have to adjoin it if you
want the same meeting that's not what
Pierre is saying okay what is here
saying
some things that
uh
relative integers yes it's a
but if you start using it you will get
weird things where you will get a zero
uh just because you had you have summed
up yes
yes so in in semorings which are which
are not positive weird things can happen
I agree but um so in retrospect would
you would you think it's a condition
that would need to be added or
uh
I I would
I would add it if I want to keep this
idea of zero labeling apps and tuples
but I'm open to some kind of
uh interpretation that says wow
the super is is a ghost
it's not really absent but you know it
was there was some difference somewhere
that that took it out but you still want
to think of it as still being around who
knows right so okay thanks
Okay so
uh examples of same meetings uh we we've
got a lot and you have already seen some
but maybe not in a very systematic way
uh in in hunger and uh in uh
here in Zhang's uh presentations
um well anything of course is a
submitting so is any distributive
lattice has to be distributive that's a
bit of assaulting and therefore any
Boolean algebra and so on but
what I want to emphasize is that there
is one semining that's very important
because annotating the tuples with
true or false is actually giving you set
semantics so everything that
you have about K relations when you make
K to be the booleans emitting
specializes to the usual
relations which are sets of tuples
just as well everything that you have
about K relations when K is the natural
numbers semi ring the one in which you
have plus times and so on
um is in fact what's called bag
semantics for positive relation algebra
there are
interesting things to discuss Beyond
positive relation algebra as to what to
do with with back semantics but these
certainly are the the basic applications
and
even though in databases we interpret
the natural number here as multiplicity
I'll just throw something out there
in my work with Eric Gradle when we
apply this in general to uh to to pursue
the logic or fixed Point logic and so on
uh natural numbers actually were
counting the number of derivations in
which a certain result
can be obtained
yes
[Music]
zero belongs to K natural numbers
ah you'd be so in trouble in my class
this is like question zero zero point
one uh all those things zero natural
number and I have to say in my class it
is this is this is the overall consensus
that it's better if we consider zero
natural number but I I know exactly what
you're talking about so the other guy
that starts with one we call them the
positive integers
whatever yeah thank you okay
yeah
um earlier you alluded to item potents
and you know we get that obviously
sometimes not always does it cause
problems or does it give us it causes
only good things so it allows us to do
more uh more identification therefore
more optimizations and so on and uh
there's a whole bunch of results that
only hold for either importance and
games
yeah I know it's it's uh it's quite
interesting
um I'll have something to see this is
best discussed when you have a big
picture of all all the semi rings
together is equal
okay the access control one remember
public uh confidential secret and top
secret
so here is an example we have to adjoin
a zero because I mean I could keep it a
top secret but that means that tuples
that are top secret are upset it doesn't
make sense so we
we are join a zero and we say tuples
that are labeled zero are so secretly
nobody can see them not even people who
stop secret clearance okay
um and
well I'll say in a moment yeah there is
this thing that
I don't know if people people of a
certain age may recall how excited what
excitement there was when zadek
introduced fuzzy
uh fuzzy logic and fuzzy mind that or
like people who all of a sudden started
to write books on fuzzy mathematics they
were just trying to take everything they
knew in math and seeing what happens
with it if you interpret it in a fuzzy
way anyway
so that's also by the way these two by
um incidentally are distributive
lattices
but there's more so you have seen the
second semi ring here this is called the
tropical semi-ring as you will see
discussed a lot tomorrow it can be used
for shortlist path it can also be used
for data pricing in a way that does not
necessarily agree with Paris and Dan's
work but you can think of these these
real values as the cost of using a tuple
and it you know it makes some sense to
if you have alternative ways to consider
the minimum
right that is I'm gonna pay only the
cheap for for the cheap price I have two
ways of paying for the same information
I'm just gonna use the the the
inexpensive
okay so
this particular segmenting though is
actually isomorphic there's an
isomorphism between these two given by
uh e e to the minus X and
the isomorphic one is exactly that same
ring in which we did the confidence
course the 0.72 if you remember it's
this one
so you take maximum and multiplication
it has a name
um it's called the viterbi semi ring not
the viterbi was particularly excited
that uh he was using semi rings but but
it's a famous algorithm in coding and
decoding and so on and it's basically
what you do in Hidden Markov Networks
yes
uh hidden Michael mobs Okay so
there's not enough space for me to
Define anything about this but you will
see Dan talking
to some extent about a variation on the
tropical semi ring in which you only
keep as it were the top K which is a
much beloved Concept in databases top K
results and I was very pleased to see
that
um I don't think these guys appear as
far as you know you didn't talk to each
other but peers student
um Jana ramusa and his thesis also is
using a very related say meaning for
some lovely results
and this one is a pods paper right
by the way these slides will be made so
underduns influence all I worked hard
and I put all the references in the
slides so actually you're gonna see the
when you go in the PDF you click on a
reference it takes you to the end of the
slides where you see the full full
reference so hopefully this will be an
additional incentive for for the people
who are
trying to become familiar with this
whole landscape of results to find
information that they can absorb
uh there's more semi rings I didn't know
about this one but the graduate student
the PHD student of my collaborator Eris
Gradle used it for some counter examples
this is called the lucasieevich semi
ring so here you have Max but for here
instead of
uh well I don't this is not a great
notation the dot but what you do is you
add add them
and if it's going to be above one you
subtract one I didn't think this was
going to be a cementing but it is
so this was
appeared apparently in some work of
famous logician lukasiewicz
on many valued logics
okay so yeah you can find it in our
paper on fixed Point logic
and it has it is itself isomorphic with
a Duo
that Eric likes to call okay well if
those were confidence course he likes to
call these scores doubt scores I leave
it to you to agree or disagree but uh
it's you know
possibly some applications could be
found for this
and the isomorphins is simply 1 minus X
okay
not that I know I mean
I said dual but I was not being precise
and yeah so but I would like at least
these two examples to fit that formal
ocean and I don't know good
okay
so uh
okay how are we doing responding
Okay so
uh
after all this okay so now we're going
to to become semi-ling aficionados uh it
turns out that it is an easy addiction
I've noticed at least some of my friends
who
who are smiling asking me so what is it
about what
15 years ago they would I say what's the
semi thing about hahaha so and then uh
and then like five years later boom they
were writing papers
um but what is it that what what was it
that at least personally convinced me
that this is so this idea has legs as it
as it were
well
um in fact it was this uh fact the the
most General expression that semi
earrings give you for provenance has
some some really wonderful properties
that algebra allows you to put to work
and that's what I'm trying to convince
you in this first part of the
presentation
so if you assume the semi-ring axioms
just like if you assume ring axioms for
expressions with in in algebra so you
may recall when whenever you were taking
Algebra 1 or Algebra 2 I don't know when
they were teaching you these things
that uh the teacher was talking about
polynomials that is if you you do the
what's the American foil you do foil
that you multiply things and so on and
you express everything as a sum of
products and so on and they were saying
okay well this is this is in polynomial
form and it has these monomials that you
add up and they have coefficients and so
on and of course in mathematics this has
had tremendous uh applications and
but it turns out that you do not need
the ring actions necessary the same
meaning actions are sufficient you take
every provenance expressions and you use
the distributivity especially it's
emitting actions and what you get
is a polynomial but the coefficients are
going to be natural numbers
okay as opposed to
in general integers or real numbers if
you like that
so
these this particular semi-ring
this is a standard mathematical notation
for polynomials
whose coefficients are natural numbers
who's in the terminates OR variables if
you like are from subset X
and this is also what's known in that
these are these are
polynomials in commutative variables
that is you write the variables like x
square y z to the fifths but you can
also you know think of it as y to the Y
is e to the fifth x square it doesn't
matter so this is called Community
variables I emphasize this
because in formal language Theory
the polynomials are not commutative
you still get some really interesting
results there but but it's a it's an
important difference
Community polynomials are easier to work
with Community variable Point numbers
so it turns out that this particular
semi ring has an algebraic property that
you know if you love algebra which
unfortunately was instilled in me from
an early age
um and I know some other people analysis
was instilled in them from an early age
if you love algebra then you kind of
have a lot of fun with these properties
okay
I mean I think you should be grateful
I'm not even talking about category
Theory
I'm making a deliberate effort not to
talk about
my pleasure forgiven
okay so it has so this particular semi
ring has a very useful property that
algebra is called a universality
property
the other thing to observe
is that these provenance polynomials for
positive relation algebra are Beta And
computable so therefore they only have a
polynomial size in the data
so this is actually this this was a
remarkable
practical fact
complexity but it was a remarkable
practical fact because we were actually
able in the first application of this
whole work which was the orchestra
system
which is a has a
DJ green and grigorous carbonarakis two
PhD students that Zach IPS and I uh
supervised at that time and who are now
established members of the community
uh were able to implement
provenance in the form of these
polynomials with only a 30 percent
overhead in the amount of data and I and
in those times you'd go and start
talking about provenance and people will
start laughing and say well do you want
me to use uh 10 times more space than
the data would take by itself because
that was the impression they had
but that's not true at all of course you
have to be clever because we use the
graph representation that to made a lot
exploited a lot
um common sub Expressions that made a
big difference okay
so the monomials of provenance
polynomials
uh correspond to Alternative logical
derivations there's a very nice
structure in this polynomials they are
actually proof that is in non-recursive
data log and also in general in data log
they correspond to logic and and
uh and so on so here here is a beautiful
um reading that you can have from the
polynomial itself so let's say you have
a tuple T and it's label it's provenance
after you've calculated it is say 2R
squared plus RS R and S are some
provenance tokens so therefore they
label some tuples in the input
what does it mean that this Tuple T has
provenance 2 r squared plus RS it means
that there are exactly three derivations
of this Tuple through your three query
Y3 well there's two of them
right here when you say two these two
two R square
and those two actually use R only
but they use each of them uses r twice
so the exponent actually tells you how
many times the Tuple was used more
interestingly it doesn't even have to be
the same Tuple it just means that it
uses tuples labeled R so you can
actually have multiple tuples in the
input
labeled with the same token and this
tells you oh I'm using uh tuples from a
particular
subset of tuples that are you know that
come from dance data for example right
I'm using them exactly two of those
and then the third derivation is RS so
that derivation uses R and S uh but each
of them just once
so this formulas actually give you a
very close
fine grain reading of how the input data
is used in the output
so how do we specialize provenance for
applications
Okay so
suppose we have provenance tokens
suppose we have two semi-rings k and l
one of them is going to be the
polynomials
and suppose we have a homomorphism I'm
not gonna Define but it's pretty clear
it preserves the plus and the times the
zero and the one
we have a homophores from K to L the
following two propositions hold first
any function the for all F any function
f from X to K that is any way of giving
evaluation of the provenance tokens in
any semi link k
has a unique extension that e with the
bank means unique extension that's a
homomorphous from polynomials into k
so if you give yourself an evaluation of
the provenance tokens in a semiting then
that uniquely extends to an evaluation
of the full
polynomials in the same meaning so
that's the universality property I
alluded to earlier in the second crucial
property is the following
for the moment please ignore
the polynomials and think here just
about two same meanings k and l
and you have a homomorphism that changes
labels so it's homologies from K to L so
if you have here K relations and you
apply that homomorphism on The
annotation of each Tuple you get an L
relation
and the same in this bottom line but the
way in which we're going to use it is
going to be K is going to be the
the polynomials so it turns out that
this also commutes
where here what you have from K
relations to K relations Is
queries from particular programming
languages query languages and we were
able to prove this fundamental property
we call it query commutation for an
impressive to me surprising
number of of query languages of course
for in the first paper we did we proved
it for conjunctive queries unions of
conjunctive queries post-dividation
Ultra non-recursive data log but we also
approved it for data log
and then later we also proved it for
semantics of
some extensions uh with for business
processes
and then we also proved it for first of
the logic and we also prefer fixed Point
logic
so there's something there that this
property captures that is very
reassuring
well in order to give the semantics you
need the assumptions on the same meeting
yes you also need the homomorphism to to
be continuous
if you have yeah but I'm just Dan's
gonna say a lot more about that so so
the deal was I don't say anything about
recursion
this last this last one that's not I
mean so because this only works for
particular queries this one is a
standard joint
this works for particular queries but
we've worked for so many different
learning languages that you know it's
kind of
pleasing to know
so I'm going to just apply this yes
education yes
well it is it's a big problem but I I
have two lectures today so I chose I
chose to discuss that in my second
lecture this is not fair it's not a fair
answer
but I'll have I'll have something to say
there yes
okay so uh so this is how you apply
those two propositions and now you see
if you have here P times R plus Q times
T you just evaluate that
in a particular scenery this is the
example with the therapy submitting for
confidence course and you get 0.72
yeah so what does it mean this means
that you can compute
provenance abstractly and then you can
apply it
for various applications
in particular any application that's
captured by assembling of course there
are also applications which are not
captured by singing okay
this is
so I only have four minutes so I'm going
to quickly show you a picture but I will
come back to this picture at the end of
the
uh at the beginning of the next lecture
okay so don't worry if you don't get
everything
now the other thing that that was
actually remarkable when for us when we
did this work is that all of a sudden
we found that different
it looked completely different
approaches to defining provenance they
were all particular cases of semi Rings
it's like
uh
here how is that there's a there's a
play by Moliere where there is a guy who
said that he never knew he was doing
Pros
yeah yeah so when I when I write a
letter I'm doing prose yeah so people
were doing say meetings without knowing
they were doing semi Rings okay okay so
um
well
I'm just gonna don't don't don't try to
understand what I'm saying so Boolean
positive Expressions I'll be back up to
this okay there is a semi ring called
which tuples are being touched uh
there's the same thing for y provenance
that was a very influential paper there
is a semi ring called Trio for for a
work that was done at Stanford in
Jennifer Williams group there is a
semi-ring
uh uh uh and
this is the picture I want to show Okay
so
because I I did learn in my long career
that it's good to end that even if it is
not really ending it's good to end on a
high note
in this picture
there are all semi Rings up here is the
polynomials there in some sense the most
General submitting uh provenance but
right below these are polynomials in
which the coefficients are Boolean and
these are the ones that you would like
to do for set semantics
yes
uh this is Trio this one is a little
bizarre we didn't know what to make of
it until TJ green had had an idea of how
to see this
so this one here you can see the set of
bags
and TJ realized you can see this one as
bags of sets
okay the why provenance that uh that one
chutan with Peter burnerman and Sanjeev
Khana introduced can be seen as sets of
sets of witnesses another Semitic
and then of course are the Boolean
Expressions this one here was the one
that was originally called lineage which
really only collects the Tuple IDs of
every Tuple that can be in one way or
another used in the derivation
uh it was called lineage but lineage now
is used in three different ways so I
just renamed it to which
and
there is a very exact sense in which
provenance higher is more informative
than provenance lowering this picture
the sense is that every arrow that you
see here is a subjective homomorphism
it's important that you subject because
it means that everything that's in the
image
can be expressed by typically more than
in more than one way in the source of
the arrow
I'll be back explaining all this and all
this item potents and absorbent at the
beginning of the
next lecture
thank you
we have time for some questions
so what you have this very nice
observation that you don't need to talk
example with one but you can say
something does this mean that you can
kind of tune your your progress point in
order to be smaller or bigger depending
on the tanks or your data
yes so what you can do is the following
instead of uh labeling every Tuple in
the input
so that that's sort of the most General
one you you basically we use Tuple IDs
so so the provenance tokens were the
Tuple IDs of every Tuple in the input
but
you can abstract you can lift your level
of abstraction say I don't care which of
these bunch of tuples is used as long as
I know it's one of those
and you take for example all the tuples
from then and you label them with d they
call the tuples from value label them
with v now you look at the final
provenance expression the polynomial
it's just going to be a polynomial in D
and V
yes and it's a lot a lot smaller
selection
so selection selection is basically
it's like joining with a relation that
has zero or one that is if it satisfies
the condition at zero if it doesn't
satisfy it's one so that was not a
difficult one too
uh no but I mean in what sense do would
you say the other operations are visible
yeah but for example plus could be
either from projection or from Union so
it's not like you can tell
um
but if you think of selection as joining
with zero one
it's a kind of joint yeah I don't know
yes well I think you can think of this
in the same way you might think of join
orders being elected by multiplication
right there there are things that we
might think of as being constraints on
Plants but we want it all to be
commutative so we'll pull the selections
to the very top and
so there's some details here to make
that pretty where we ignore things we
might want to know otherwise yeah
a lot of questions yes
um can you say a little bit about what
you get out of uh specializing the uh
simmering even further because you said
again uh earlier in the talk that
implementing The Province polynomial has
a manageable overhead so if we
specialize our scenario further is it
even less overhead if you choose not to
not do okay so
there are problems with data Rock but
for for in the absence of recursion all
these are polynomials but if you go here
for example the polynomial is a lot
smaller it's called an absorptive
polynomial
and you could choose to only keep these
provenance if you are only interested in
for example
confidence scores and probabilistic
interpretations and things like that
what you cannot do here is of course A
Reason about the number of
about Multiplicity but a lot of people
are totally happy with that so are we
only talking about sort of runtime
performance there or does you know the
these additional properties of mercenary
give us more I don't know query
optimizations that we could do or
something like that uh yeah so you well
so the query optimizations are about
equating not about the prominence right
I think of it as
so that's actually a very simple Point
thank you for asking
the greater organizations halfway the
question is is your provenance
collection still sound if the query has
been optimized
and that we have a good understanding of
in particular
remember that the access control circuit
okay so that is some kind of
distributive that is it's a very simple
one uh public confidential figure but
for example what if you want uh three
different levels of of confidential for
three different departments but they're
not comparable with each other turns out
that's not the distributive lines
and what that means is that if you apply
on your query and optimization that uses
distributivity of join over then uh then
you cannot actually
wait until the end and apply the
provenance so so so that's informative I
think as a as a way of dealing with
so you you can choose and of course uh
when we were working on our Orchestra of
course Zach sedono we're going to
implement the most General one and for
every Tuple ID
but I can see
whatever I do a possible application I
don't know what Pierre also has
implemented
the problem that we implement the
multinational one but
yeah
sure
especially in the sense that when you go
down this hierarchy or e-lighting
information that is essentially
asserting equivalences in the underlying
language you're saying but because I'm
not keeping this information I'm
asserting that either way it could have
been set up higher up I will consider to
be equivalent lower down so for instance
in the case of selections if we if we
cared about Equity joints for some
reason let's say we were doing outer
joints where they're not distributive
right I guess it's exactly the example
you're making you need more information
than the top of this picture right yeah
so it has something to do with the
axioms of your your language yeah
an interesting uh question is the
following which I will ask of
Dan's and other people who are into
probabilistic database
well if you only keep this kind of
provenance
you are limited which is Boolean
Expressions you are limited in reasoning
about Multiplicity
and if you care somehow to do
probabilistic databases but still you
care about multiplicity it's not clear
how to marry the two of them but in
practice uh SQL system user back
semantics anyway so uh
anyway because
well you just keep purposeful but on
everything
another possibility is to use your work
on singing modules
okay
let's talk about that don't worry yeah
the Aggregate and also distribution over
the past
cool
yep
[Music]
okay thank you
[Applause]